[Music]
what is
ai and what is it not
the simplest explanation for ai is a
system that gets better through learning
but it's busy learning something
and that's probably the easiest and
current definition of it
when i say ai to my non-technical
friends they typically think of a movie
that they saw
and the movie always has a robot and the
robot goes awry
and that robot is slain by a female
scientist
who triumphs
and
i propose a variant of that movie where
the computers all conspire against
humans and start killing humans
the humans notice this the computers run
away from the humans
right and the humans and a female
scientist
figures out how to unplug the computers
one by one by one
that's not what ai is that's a movie
fiction
and it'll be a very long time hopefully
never they will have to deal with that
what ai really is is a system of
knowledge
that is implemented inside the cloud so
it's around you all the time
and it's very good at looking at large
data sets and predicting things
it's very good at looking and finding
patterns that humans can't see
i mentioned earlier that computers were
very good at vision
that was the first breakthrough
but what they're now doing is looking
for patterns of correlation that humans
can't see so let's imagine that on
tuesday you do something and on friday
someone else does something and it turns
out that you're magically linked in the
universe such that tuesday causes friday
but it's not a pattern that's apparent
computers can discover that pattern that
needle in a haystack particularly well
when you operate this stuff at scale
you end up with systems
that look human-like
because they can aggregate data and they
can think what you think they can
generate
a solution there's a technology called
gans generative adversarial networks
where the computer can generate
candidates and another network says not
good enough not good enough not good
enough until they find it
gans have been used for example to build
pictures of actresses and actors that
are fake but look so real you're sure
you know them
so one of the concerns the one of the
real concerns about ai
is that it's going to be very difficult
to tell the difference between
information and misinformation
and i'll give you an example let's
assume that all of your readers and
listeners are obviously human and that
the standard rules of humans apply to
all of us
there's something called anchoring bias
there's something called recency bias
you know people aren't completely
rational computers nor should they we
don't want them to be we love humans
but let's imagine the computer gets
enough of such people and it figures out
that if i say the following outrageous
thing first you'll always believe me
and the computer discovers this and so
all of a sudden
everything it does boom boom boom
i thought a lot about the way
politicians speak if you watch carefully
they take a set of phrases and they
repeat them over and over again they're
simple phrases that's anchoring they're
trying to get the audience their voters
to start with this fact and then judge
past it well computers will be
incredibly good
at exploiting that
that means that the world our social
world around us within the next decade
will become impossibly confusing
because there's so many actors that will
want to misinform us businesses
politicians our opponents for fun god
knows we don't know how to manage that
you